righty joe musgrove with start number 17
for san diego five wins six losses 2.97
era 94 innings 63 hits 34 runs 31 earned
he's walked only 23 he has fanned 110.
top of your right back through musgrove
cronenworth going to try and make
another great defensive play but osmer
can't grab it and top you might have
beaten it out anyway
we have seen jake do just about
everything on the right side of the
infield one can do defensively that
would have been extra special and an
infield single to start the first
against joe the one one ground ball to
the right side diving play by jake
cornerworth from the knees in time
oh what a play by jake that's the reason
he's going to the all-star game and you
can hang a star on that one what a
terrific play going to his left 1-2 fly
ball to center field grisham starts back
now he's going to come running in now
will myers is going to call him off to
make a catch and that'll do it for the
rockies here in the first so a lead-off
single leads to nothing on the hill for
colorado they're all-star their lone
all-star right-hander jeremiah marquez
26-year-old making his 19th start for
his career at petco park 2-2-4-8-6
that's dirty tatis is the first
strikeout victim for airmon marcus 02
pitch
he'll hit it to the right side
three bouncer to garrett hampson his
counterpart at second garrett throws him
out and airmon marquez with another
scoreless inning we head to the second
and that's a good looking swing on a
slider base hit for fuentes
second hit for the rockies tough to
string hits together against musgrove
rocky's almost did that in the first
got him first drink out of the night for
jill musgrove owens is down two away one
two swung on a missed strike three he
got him and with the ball second strike
out of the evening for joe
and he works out of the second inning
without allowing any runs no runs one
hit one runner stranded we've played an
inning and a half osmore at 259 playing
in his 83rd game of the season 300
hitter against marquez and he greets him
here with a liner into the left field
corner opposite field extra basis for
haas and into second with a two out
double first pitch hacking and still has
that high 90s fastball 2-2 is the
breaking ball swinging and a miss he got
him
second strikeout for airmon the padres
strand of man in scoring position no
score after two a runner in scoring
position for hampson the pitch so we're
going to miss strike three this time he
got him no foul tip
no ball in the dirt just a strikeout
third strike out of the evening for joe
musgrove
two way here in the third cj krone with
runners on first and second and two down
here in the top of the third right
right-hander's o2 pitch popped up right
side kroner worth going back for it will
myers coming on grisham coming on it's
going to be will myers to finally call
it at the last second and to make the
catch a good job by will to take control
of the situation he records the final
out
rocky strand two at the end of two and a
half inning no score yet between the
padres and the rockies
first pitch hacking and victor
guaranteed through the left side a lead
off single victor's gonna take a slow
turn around first base no chance of
thinking about two but he gets things
started here for the padres in the top
of the third another one two and it's
bunted foul to the backstop and it's a
strikeout as musgrove will head back to
the dugout now comes set with the hand
in the glove and the 2-2 breaking ball
is a called strike three at the top of
the zone
wonderful pitch by airmon marquez to get
tommy pham looking for strikeout number
four
mark is ready 1-2 pitch rolled to the
left side taken by owings goes the short
way to hampson at second and that'll do
it airmon marquez
leaves carratini after the lead off
single on to the fourth quick inning
would be nice here for joe musgrove
got him
that's number four for joe
oh it's the old number two the yakker
got him looking again the 3-2 pitch
strike three swing and a miss
joe finally able to retire fuentes on
strike second strikeout of the inning
fifth strike out of the evening for him
the pitch strike three called
got him
joe musgrove strikes out the side from
the fourth his first one two three
inning of the night and it came at the
perfect time between innings here at
petco park announced that he will be an
all-star
fifth of his career and a nice uh video
board announcement in the middle of the
fourth inning for manny as the padres
now have five all-stars for the first
time since 1998. that's awesome
congratulations manny jake cronenworth
started off against
airmon marquez and then manny machado
and trent grisham
1-1 pitch swing and a miss and that's
actually a one-two pitch and the throw
down to first base gets cronenworth
there is strikeout number five
one-two pitch called strike three and a
dandy of a breaking ball froze machado
ready in the 3-2 pitch called strike
three breaking ball on the outside
corner down goes grisham number seven
for marquez and he strikes out the side
in the fourth ace is loaded now the
veteran rocky left fielder is 0 for one
tonight he ground it out in the first
inning 1-2
and this ball on the ground through the
right side herrmond scores top he'll
score hampson at third two-nothing
colorado charlie blackman coming through
and they knock joe busgrove out of the
ball game
kind of poked out to right myers coming
in and will is there to make the catch
hampson thought about it but retreats
and a strong throw home that's out
number two
going pitch another fly ball to right
field this one playable little drifting
over to his left a little bit he has a
beat on it he makes the catch for the
final out so a nice job by austin adams
who comes in with runners on first and
third and one out he loaded the bases
himself but he's able to work out of it
and keep the damage to a minimum but the
rockies do get two
yeah what a great career uh
craig stamina has put together he's a
workhorse 39th game this year for the
veteran right-hander 50-plus innings
next pitch to him driven to center field
grisham is going to come in and in in
dives makes the catch
a great diving catch by trent grisham
had to come running in towards his left
laid out at the last second to make the
play five solid innings only two hits
eight strikeouts incredibly efficient in
those five shutout innings for marquez
and he's gonna get a
pop up to
what
shallow
play
chris owens
with a great play profar was already at
second base
it does not get any better than this one
two to tati swang and a miss
armond marquez with strikeout number
nine
great defense
and the rockies lead it after six first
and third no one out
got him blackman strikes out and a huge
first down for johnson here in the
seventh inning just a ground ball away
getting out of this first and third jam
one away top of the seventh is a two
nothing rockies lead
this ball lifted to plenty deep right
center field myers will make the catch
tapia tags and cruises home with the
rocky's third run
so cj krohn got a pitch he could handle
his 34th rbi three-nothing colorado
sears grisham with cronin worth over at
first and one out
one strike pitch grounded to the right
side taken by hampson little side flip
to owings back to first in time to get
the speedy grisham and airman marquez
gets the double play and closes the door
on the padres in the seventh he's got
the shutout going
bart is
12-17 in save opportunities this year
but he's got the first two outs here in
the bottom of the ninth inning
on the ground to second what a job
seven beautiful innings for hermann
carlos steve as the eighth daniel barty
no drama ninth and the rockies end the
nine game slide in san diego with a
three-nothing shutout of the very
talented padre
club